we begin with this of course Porto Rico
Zim battled governor Ricardo Raphael was
stepping down after 12 days of historic
New Times violent protests
Rocio announced his resignation in a
Facebook live video late last night and
then the demonstrations turned to
celebration in the streets he will leave
office next Friday August 2nd this
follows massive protests on the island
they were set off by a leaked derogatory
group chat that allegedly proved
corruption inside the Rocio
administration CTM lead national
correspondent David beg no has been
covering the unrest from Puerto Rico
since it began and he was outside the
governor's mansion when protesters
learned the news David what was like
that what was that moment like Tony it
wasn't just euphoric and energetic to
sort of witness what was happening it
was historic you realized as you stood
in this very spot yesterday that 25
years from now people are going to talk
about what happened when Millennials
stood on those barricades and said he
has to go Ricardo Roe say you'll became
the poster boy for protesters who want
to be rid of corruption in this
administration but he also represented
decades of mismanagement that protesters
had been targeting let me tell you how
it went last night nobody knew when the
message was coming there were thousands
of protesters here all of a sudden the
video starts playing and everyone went
silent watch this
just before midnight the crowd went
quiet protestors huddled around their
phones and speakers listening to
governor ricardo rosado stoke a continue
are any opposition after hours of delay
rosa you'll finally said the words these
people had been waiting 12 days to hear
i will be resigning
[Applause]
Puerto Rican rapper resident a who has
largely led the protest was in tears
after my song Berg this is the happiest
moment of my life this is incredible
I've been waiting for this moment since
I'm a little kid with my father
the governor's resignation is a massive
victory for many Puerto Ricans who for
decades had protested corruption in this
government and fought for change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
celebrations spread throughout the city
of San Juan crowds cheered sang they set
off fireworks at one point people
outside the governor's mansion even
broke into the electric slide which is
so popular here
the people we talk to feel that Rosie
owes resignation proves there is
strength in numbers some of the
headlines people are waking up to this
morning
Puerto Rico kicked him out you will not
make a fool out of us listen the
governor's part of an ongoing
investigation even though he's leaving
his cell phone has been surrendered as
part of that chat scandal that he's
being investigated along with 11 other
people who were involved in the chat and
the investigation is being conducted by
the Department of Justice the woman who
runs the Department of Justice is next
in line to be the governor of Puerto
Rico her name is Wanda Vasquez and as it
stands right now she will become the
governor when Ricardo Rocio leaves in a
week I should tell you that one thing
that stood out last night when we were
here with the protesters is that for the
first time in a long time when they
heard the governor's say I'm resigning
they felt heard heard by their own
government shows you the power of the
people their voice David whatever
happens next we know you'll be on the
ground there to tell us about it David
beg no in Puerto Rico for us thank you
David that's all anybody wants so really
is to be heard be heard you have placed
in power I want to find out how the
electric slide became so popular in
Puerto Rico I can be an investigative
piece for David Neff it works in all
circumstances the electric behind all
right David no for us there in Puerto
Rico thank you very much